كان ضاملينا في السجاد عبد الرحمن القدس
مسؤوله جناح لمري في القريه العالميه اهلا
بك يسعد صباحكم نورنا في الاستديو ما الذي
يميز الرقص اليمني الشعبي
الفن اليمني مختلف
مختلف
العالميه نحرص كل الحرص على
التميز في
الفنون اليمنيه
كاربجهات اليمن
طيب عبد الرحمن خلينا كمان نعرف انواع
الرقصات اشقرها يعني اليمن بلد كبير متنوع
جغرافيا وحتى ثقافيه باختلاف الاقساطه
في الجنوب اليمن في شمال اليمن
اوكي شمال اليمن في الرقصات البراء
والمزمار البرق
وفي كمان عده رقصات هذا في شمال اليمن كل
الجنوب الجنوب يتميز بالرقصات عديده كثيره
الرقصات الاحذيه الحضرميه في عده همم
الفلكلور اليمني او رقص اليمني لا يختلف
بيحس بالمكان والمناطق ولكن بحسب تنوع
المناسبات كيف ذلك
في همم كل منطقه لها تقاليد وعادات
انت عم بتقول لي على الاختلاف انواع
الرقصه انا قلت في رقصه الحضرمي وفي
صنعاني واللحجه يعني كل حسب المنطقه لكن
طريقه العرض بماذا تختلف يعني هل في عدد
معين من الراقصين اسلوب معين استخدام الف
معينه
كان عندنا منطقه في الشمال
الرقصات كلها بالمزمار والبراء ما يستخدم
للعود ولا العود
وفي مناطق كمان في صنعاء في الشمال
وكمان ايضا عبد الرحمن فقط نريد ان نشير
ايضا الى مشاهدينا انه بعد قليل سنذهب
لمتابعه الرقص الحيري الرقص الشعبي اليمني
ونشير الى انه ضيفنا استاذ عبد الرحمن
يتحدث عن رقصه البرع وهي واحده من اشهر
الرقصات التي يتميز بها اليمن تعتبر سيده
الرقصات اليمنيه وايضا دخلت يونسكو صنفتها
يونسكو على لائحه التراث غير المادي عام
2010 فقط نريد ان نشير ايضا الى ذلك
من الشعر الرقصات اليمنيه
طيب استاذ عبد الرحمن يعني هل الرقص
اليمني مقتصر فقط على الرجال ام للنساء
ايضا راقصات النساء
هذه في جنوب اليمن
اجتمع فيه الرقصات الحريم الرجال